alors la justice refuse le prénom et
griezmann les maps et on va dire le
tweet détiennent sur une info qui a
beaucoup fait parlé ce week-end pour
mais pourquoi ils s'appellent pas
simplement leurs enfants antoine ou
qu'il ya ne comprends pas un couple
apparemment très fan de foot a voulu
donner un nom très particulier à leur
bébé mais la justice a refusé regarder
on vous explique tout le 15 juillet
dernier l'équipe de france de football
inscrivez sur notre maillot une deuxième
étoile tant attendu en remportant la
coupe du monde des millions de français
sont devenus de véritables fans de deux
stars du foot qu'il y en ait mbappé et
antoine griezmann
nombreux sont les français qui ont
honoré à leur manière cette jeune équipe
de france certains par des tatouages
d'autre part des tee-shirts
mais un couple corrézien avait quant à
lui décidé d'aller plus loin en tentant
de donner comme prénom à leur nouveau-né
griezmann et mbappé en hommage aux deux
attaquants des bleus mais ce week-end le
couperet est finalement tombé et cette
requête pour le moins originale a été
refusée par un juge aux affaires
familiales qui a considéré que ce prénom
était de nature à porter préjudice à
l'enfant
suite à cette décision l'enfant a
finalement été appelé danino et le nom
il est il est rayé des registres de
l'état civil mais il reste conserver sur
l'acte de naissance
donc ça ira quand même gilbert d alors
depuis 1993 on a plus de liberté mais il
faut que le prénom comporte des lettres
de l'alphabet français et qui ne porte
pas préjudice et on a refusé récemment
un nom qui était un nom de marque
des parents avaient appelé leurs enfants
nutella non awek te ment et ça a été
refusé
on n'a pas le droit de faire ça ils ont
dû changer le prénom revois je voulais
appeler mon fils au piquet jr et
heureusement mais heureusement qu'elle
est là justice sur un coup comme ça
imaginez donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
quelqu'un il kiffe touche pas à mon
poste il a appelé son fils hanouna
beinheim en prenne enfin je veux dire c
est faux non mais faut quand même si
vous n'aimez pas pourquoi ce prénom à
mon enfant a coûté beauvau j'adorerais
comme moi croient pas beaucoup sur la
france accueillera benhaim prévoit là et
ça vous fera les pieds au champ
tellement d'accord avec le tweet qui a
été fait christmann s'appartient rissman
bapès appartient maps et donc autant
appelé antoine et killian sort et c'est
se rendre hommage et s'en sent que ça
porte préjudice plus tard parce
qu'effectivement quand on donne
maintenant un enfant faut quand même
savoir qu'ils le valent porteur soit 50
60 ans ou alors ya un père vrai ou faux
un père appelait son fils zidane henry
barthez c'est un père brésilien qui a
voulu rendre hommage aux joueurs vrai ou
faux un couple et son enfant caris booba
octogone un couple a appelé son enfant
rien ah oui une petite rihanna est née
ouais c'est vrai est vrai ou faux un
couple ap son enfant gilles verdez joey
starr tarte à la crème